ein neues thema übrigens der letzte
jetzt für heute haben wir ein
führerschein und welches auto hättet ihr
gerne ich mache zurzeit mein
führerschein ich also ich hab den
fahrradführerschein der vierten klasse
gemacht wie eigentlich ist es also mein
mein bruder den man ja aus dem eine aus
der einnahmen asse oder den 23 amnesia
folgen kennt der hat einen
fahrradführerschein fertig ich habe mich
dann erst in der grundschule irgendwo
vorbei gefahren des lebens hat sich eine
verfahren beim ihrer klasse obwohl er
genau den opfern
obwohl julia encke so fassten stehen
also so dass es irgendwo nicht abgebogen
in der grundschule er kam auch
todtraurig nach hause kann sich noch
ganz genau daran erinnern und jetzt ist
der in amerika oder er macht auslands
austauscht ja so aus wie es da warm
postet dauern bilder vom strand und so
direkt indirekt an ostküste steht auch
eine square ja jetzt gut glaube ich da
muss man sich keine sorgen machen das
war das jeweils 3.000 führerschein
vielleicht ein welches auto gerne
mercedes slk oder ein audi am 5 warum er
dennoch sl haben kannst findest lka
sieht so wie eine echt scheiße variante
scheiß kleine baby variante vom sl aus
ja genau deswegen auch weil damit kannst
du dich identifizieren
aber mercedes an sich ist oder präferenz
oder koenigsegg wenn es gut läuft später
ccx soll wieder als keine ahnung rcs
werde ich nicht vorhanden
das sind immer so opfer autos wendig ob
es hat so ein image davon zu finden sind
bis hin zu wissen so ich weiß gar nicht
was ich du wolltest du nicht leisten
kannst
ich weiß nicht ob ich so viel geld ein
auto investieren würde wenn ich jetzt so
viel geld haben vielleicht aber ich
hätte gern vernünftiges also muss ein
erstes auto wird auf keinen fall
mercedes reparierten golf sie mir
reichen und wir reichen 500 ps 600 schon
über 100 sollte das auto schon haben
weil sein quartett
ich könnte so gar nicht sagen was für
ein auto zum ein traumauto rea muss ich
ehrlich sagen meine eltern meine eltern
haben doch so ein opel meriva der
schlecht 560 ps oder so und das ist
eines unserer autos und keine ahnung was
wahrscheinlich nicht fahren
ich habe deine mutter gehört wieder mama
du bist schon wieder auf youtube
ich liebe euch alle
das video zeigt dieses video wenn ihr
auch mein kurzes mutter gehört habt den
allemal division lag wenn ihr euch das
video grad anguckt
daumen hoch für diese aktion hin daumen
hoch dass ich live bilder werden aber
die kommentare seien im nach dem motto
ihr habt ihr auch gehört daumen hoch für
diesen kommentar wenn ihr sie auch
genannt hast ja ja den blick durch ein
trio leicht diesen kommentar damit sie
ihnen auch lesen
also ich meine band get shorty sich fast
alle kommentare ich gucke halt immer mal
ab und zu rein und jeder ein paar seiten
sind also ich nicht ehrlich auf keine
kommentare eingehen heißt nicht dass ich
die nicht lesen
mehr noch eine pn neulich geschrieben
du bist voll nett weil auch kommentare
antwort alle anderen lpr lesen die nur 1
oder taten meist aber nur auf
vernünftige sachen und nicht auf den
scheiß egal woher du musik und
beschreibung steht oben drin ja und mich
selbst auch immer wenn ich wenn ich auf
den kommentar antwort dann steht er ganz
oben ist er so hervorgehoben
wenn also fragen sind was für ein mikro
hast du heute zu irgendeiner folge das
hat doch nichts mit der folge zu tun was
wir im mikro ich hab dann soll das nicht
ganz oben stehen nebenbei stets aber auf
main kanal dick und fett auf meinem
effekt für alles
dann schreib hin steht in öfen crew aber
wenn ich das dann schreibe ich als
antwort steht im effekte und auf dem
kanal dass jeder das ganz oben auf dem
video und das nervt mich mit mit weil
das solche fragen wir auch von größeren
kanal gemacht weil ich habe das feuer
bei facebook gehabt aber dann ist es
wieder so ein klick den die leute machen
müssen von einem kanal auf facebook das
kann man doch nicht zumuten
deswegen habe ich einmal direktor von
einer domain gold mine aus zieht aus wie
ein bunker und auch schon wenn das im
aufklappbaren bereich ist schauen sie
sich nicht an einer technischen standard
sie sagen mir ich habe auf dem kanal
nicht gefunden wo das ist allgemein
beschreibung gucken da steht so einiges
drin sticks ich habe leider keine mehr
ich glaub ich jetzt nach hause die folge
ist oft gehört auch ich gehe doch nach
hause
ich habe immerhin richtig viel eisen
gefunden eigentlich auch apples viele
aber keine folge sind jetzt eigentlich
jetzt sind wir bei der achten folge
denke ich mal bin ich auch danach noch
auf bin ich total ausgelaugt kein
wochenende aus einem fertigen schon seit
und war an drei stil des rc und bin nur
wirklich am aufnehmen und alles ist echt
krass welt nach paris
bisher sind sie das leben mich bestimmt
schon längst wieder zurück muss den
ausgang finden
und noch was essen wir wollen mit dieser
stress mit den hunger games in den
ganzen zeug und keiner ahnen
es war dann auch wieder er muss heute
morgen noch lernen und welche montag
diese physik mister schreibe und ich
weiß nicht mehr über was für sechs auch
gut klausur also bei privaten gehe ich
auch immer also bei pence bei youtube
oder bei facebook die auch mal nach dem
aufwand des anderen der einfach nur so
in alles alles klein geschrieben einen
satz nicht mal hallo oder sowas oder ich
hätte eine meine frage sind einfach nur
was dein mikro nano mikro anschreiben
faq eingeschrieben so gleiche aufwand
für beide
und wenn jemand weiß er wenn jemand
vielleicht das wirklich nicht gefunden
hatte aber sich dann mühe gibt ja sorry
ich hab echt lange gesucht aber
irgendwie nicht gefunden
da bleib ich ihm auch arbeit schreibe
sieben prozent ja entweder blind auf
beiden augen lassen das muss ja mein
erhalten
mann ich will jetzt raus ich finde
ausgang mich und ich hab ja keine spitze
kommt irgendwie hoch zu kommen jetzt
muss ich mich hier schon wieder meine
ganzen couples leben namen alter du bist
die welt weit unten
ja ich muss mir irgendwie hoch bauen ich
dachte schon jemand du bist gestorben
mal wieder schwarz ich ziehe jetzt mal
was auch ich hab's gar nicht auf den
ausgang 3 ich habe ihn okay
wohin geht die lager hier neue high
score schätzt ihr 9 11 111 x also in
minecraft backe könnt euch den discount
anschauen
ach so wiederum zum film bestimmt bitte
durfte fleisch jawohl man diese für
diese schafe sind jetzt kann ich auch
noch ein paar monster ja immer diese
tiere ne echt doof hier zur tiere ganz
viele tiere in der konfi hier tritt
keine reaktion
grass salami hoffen dass du das hörst
bis zu 100 blöcke unterm jemand all das
was ich hier mein gott was mach ich bin
aber immer wenn man hoch will sieht man
noch über eisen und kohle ja und dann
ich habe keine stimme mehr gehabt
der diamant gefunden nein bitte nicht
unfähig oder ist
ich bin ein mann und gehen den kampf
ohne waffen und ohne rüstung
dass frau endlich mal weiblicher gast
hätte auch ich dachte mir extra
eingeladenen frauen code hoch zu halten
manchmal nicht schon wieder denkt
das dachte ja schon als wir als wir
deutschen eingeladen haben aber schon
wieder nicht funktioniert echt gar
nichts passiert uns echt immer wieder
ich glaub ich laufe hat eine komplett
falsche richtung
jaja ich weiss es sogar sie aber gleich
eine fackel mehr
es geht hier mal so leicht hoch und
wieder runter ich habe wieder eine fette
höhle gefunden
doch ich glaube ja wirklich so aus wie
unser anfangs berg da wo wir nehmen an
dass monsanto
ich will wenigstens hochkommen wie hoch
bin ich denn 32 38 blöcke nach oben muss
jetzt haben hier grade schneller
schneller schneller schneller dass es so
scheiße aufwendig hier sehe ich wollte
mich in einen berg hoch dass mir nicht
gut
so hört 200 immer noch im graben ich
sehe auch gar nichts mehr aber ich bin
mir hierbei mit dem den astag auch kein
licht
ok ich mach mal nicht ich habe ihm gar
nichts das jetzt vom unten krieg auch
gelaufen kommt so dr
es wäre nicht gut
ich nehme hier verfällt zweites
frühstück heute morgen wecker gestellt
ich habe ich hier fast verschlafen das
patent hat diesen tollen iphone wecker
alarm eine richtig geile für android
gentle alarm oder auf deutsch und sie
als auf englisch aber auf deutsch heißt
das glaube ich sanfter bäcker oder sowas
eine art der suche nach in dem schlaf
rhythmus drin das jahr kam aber dass man
verpennte einfach nicht mit dem weil der
das g8 du kannst acht minuten einstellen
dass es acht minuten lang sanft
einblendet und dann noch zehn minuten
läuft also kein kannst alles ganz genau
einstellen und dann werden auch dieses
nutzt sachen also dass wir wieder drauf
durchschnitt schlimmer modus hörst
schlimmer modus wird dann kannst du noch
einstellen wie lange er sein soll und
wir und dann wird er immer jedes mal ein
paar minuten kürzer und ganz nach drei
schwimmer modus kommt dann so ein idiot
also nerviges und davon durch
hundertprozentig wach am ende
ich habe noch nie verstanden früher habe
ich immer verschlafen jetzt galaxy nexus
hat also das google-handy nächstes jahr
kenne ich hatte kumpel von mir auch zwei
stück css3 coup ist an mir haben die
aber der hat auch schon als zweiter alle
handys hat alle wirklich alle nächste
iphone 5 gestellt und kommt genau in
zwei monaten in zwei monaten york weil
apple das alles ist nicht mehr grün also
wieder abbestellen er ja eigentlich
dabei meinen vertrag hier aufgelaufen
und ich krieg zum gleichen preis wie als
wenn ich das jetzt verlängern würde von
daher ja aber wie viel zeit sie für dein
vertrag pro monat 40 ja ganz schön teuer
über eine internet flat 495 pro monat oh
ja und ich war von mittlerweile braucht
wirklich internet eröffnet mir nicht ich
habe genau hier 50 freiminuten 50 frei
sms und internet flat nach 500 gb
gedrosselt und deutschland sind hier 100
frei sms 100 freiminuten und internet
500 mb datenvolumen
januar dezember ab hier mit schicken ich
habe genau das gleiche war wie ihr und
ich bezahle nur 94
wer wieviel interview hast du 100 wie
kannst du das gemacht werden das gemacht
was jetzt antworten mark noble kennt
doch coppola das ist immer diese
anbieter sowie rabatte und er war von
blau oder grün blau oder rot uhr das
also was drin für 498 habe sagte ich mir
ich hab ja ich habe kein vertrag ich hab
mir das erst drei also samsung galaxy s3
habe ich mir einzigen geholt und hat mir
dann ist er aber auch aber was hast du
denn dann wird
wieviel inklusivvolumen hattest du
nochmal beim bds ist das ist echt gut
ich würde sagen wir kommen zum ende der
nacht
ich bin ja schon oben ich wollte mir
noch mal ganz kurz ein haus angucken
dann wesentlich ertingen
der punkt ist der bunker als erich braun
anstellt okay ich weiß aber ungefähr wo
ich hin muss das ding ist nur dass ich
gleich wieder essen brauchen von der
höhle kommst musst du in richtung f0
habe ich irgendwo es meine ich nicht
weil ich habe null zu essen das ist gar
nicht gemein kreft wackelt laufe schon
könnt ihr schon mal etwas angepisst auf
jeden fall nicht sehr weit gekommen
ich bin da wo und wo reingefallen sind
die mauer man hat ja immer noch holz ich
muss man hingehen ich muss mein schild
auf dem ein schild
der bunker ich habe eigentlich die ganze
zeit nur gepasst hat gar keine
fensterscheiben gibt geld habe ich bei
dir in der kiste nicht gefunden
das ist auch hier dass überall sand
überall sand oder hättest du ein wort
gesagt hätte gegeben ein wort gesagt
hätte du auch was gegeben so ist ja
nicht nur das gefühl ich ja gibt ihm
sogar schweine reichtum auch schlimme
ist schon krass
crank that crash etwa das niveau seiner
branche ist mit fünf wochen urlaub so
anstrengend war war ich hasse diesen
computern
wieso ich manchmal denke ich dieser
dieser den erst voll intelligent aber
mal zu mal mehr so dumm
was feststeht ist auch fertig ich hätte
auch ein stück geben könnt so wirst du
immer im nachhinein
ich glaube ich bin auch auf malware hier
aber etwas falsch gemacht
ich bin nämlich noch ein weg erst war
ich - nur jetzt nicht +0 so leute wie
uns sind nun die das haus von minecraft
marketing
wenn mein erstes sogar etwas hast du ist
dass dieser dingsbums motto best case
mod ist das cape hast das sind cape ich
hab kein geld du hast du hast bist du
ich habe kein geld ich weiß woran es
liegt dadurch gefaked es gibt seitdem
sie capes da kannst du dir so capes
machen und jeder in motten hat sie ist
dieses cape und um sich einzuloggen gibt
es einfach nur ein user nehmen also
konkreter in dem fall und ein passwort
das man noch immer haben möchte zum
beispiel felix gibt's das passwort ein
das wort und kannst dann einfach von dem
skin einfach hinten escape auswählen und
du hast jetzt dieses case gay was wollen
diese scheiße alle und jetzt hast du das
cape weiteren habe und bei mehr als sie
zuletzt ok
zum glück kam die dann in welche
beleidigung oder so draufgeschrieben
anzeigen jaja das haus an sich ich würde
note 6 geben aber sehr schön geworden
6 + com da kannst du deine sachen
vielleicht hier wie sich das drin was
passiert beim haus ist jetzt mein gott
bio transformer haus baute vielleicht
sollte ich beim fertig der langweiler
hat so sogar dann komplett an die sachen
einfach bock auf phoenix in der kiste
ich habe eine kiste also okay gut wir
wollten ja so ein start ausbauen
nächstes mal oder wir bei uns einfach
auf screen das machen wir schon haben
wir schon das schaffen wir
der bunker bei m7 bocket zu ok gut wie
weg hier einstellen
nein kam das passt wir haben in dieser
aufnahme menge geschafft ihr wir waren
in einer höhle doch an dem ich außerdem
letztes die farm weiter gebaut um 1,6 im
plus
und ich würde einfach sagen dass ich es
gibt keine 6 plus gibt das ergebnis
nicht jegliche illusion und damit auch
einfach schwarz ich wohl kurz wolle das
geht jetzt hier in 23 sekunden ist
einfach ein abgeschlossenes haus in der
today show muss ein wettbieten bei dem
dogma das geht nicht anders wäre wo ich
mir hole ich mir wo ich mir ich bin
gleich da muss ich wieder hier diese
kakteen videos oder kakteen getan
erzählt es mir ist es nicht überall kann
ich sicher wieder fünf videos über die
zeit das wird nicht mehr lange letzte
folge europas thron als ob du eine
chance hat 12 sa er hat hast du da
überhaupt schon holz so er habe er hat
holzburg vom wem ist eigentlich dieser
ic wagen so heißt ich aus ich hier auch
ich war mal wieder packt ihre kirche
kirchen kirchen kann ich gar nicht kann
ich kann wo bist du musst du dein haus
laufen hier schon zu deinem haus leon
deportiert mich mal bitte wo ich bin
hier wieder hängen geblieben
so wie immer geistig hängen geblieben
richtig gut erkannt eigentlich braucht
ein doppelbett aber ich kenne ich dir
nicht
herrmann ich bin so xxl mäßig deswegen
gestrichen
ich verbitte gut ich würde sagen ja ich
will hier die ganze zeit sagen bis zum
nächsten mal aber irgendwie kommen wenn
die dazu alter ich habe keine lust doch
zu lange warte warte ich dachte kann
jetzt töten menschen irgendwo uns nichts
tipi micro ist sage ich mal danke an
minecraft ist es nicht schön
vielen dank son showerdrain bis zum
nächsten mal